treasury secretary janet yellen she's
super well respected in the finance
world but she hasn't been a fan of
bitcoin or cryptocurrencies in fact she
came out multiple times over the last
few years and said she ain't about that
game well i don't know what happened but
somehow janet yellen
she's done a 180. and janet yellen not
only is she a fan of bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies but now she's out here
preaching the good word what am i
talking about in a recent speech listen
right here to what janet yellen had to
say about bitcoin in 2008 a person or
group of people
using the pseudonym satoshi nakamoto
proposed a decentralized
peer-to-peer system for making and
processing payments a key challenge in
digital payments is to prevent the same
assets from being spent twice the
bitcoin white paper proposed a novel
method for validating transactions
using cryptography that address the
so-called double spend problem this and
other innovations related to distributed
ledger technology are the foundation for
based digital assets
what i had to watch that like six
different times i for sure thought that
was a fake video i thought you know
where they go ahead and they use the
ventriloquist or maybe it was some sort
of edited thing nope i triple checked
it's real janet yellen is all in on the
bitcoin cryptocurrency train what does
that mean for the united states i'm not
really sure does this mean the united
states is going to create regulation
that's friendly probably does it mean
that the treasury or the federal reserve
may go start buying bitcoin unlikely
what i do know is that eventually
everyone capitulates janet yellen spent
years and years and years knocking
against bitcoin but now she's up here
literally given history lessons who's
satoshi how does the double spin problem
work why is a blockchain valuable that
is a pretty big turnaround from somebody
who couldn't even bring themselves to
say bitcoin in many of her speeches
years ago and so ultimately this is what
we're gonna watch happen politicians
regulators appointed people and
ceos of various companies they're all
going to capitulate don't listen to what
they did say just watch what they're
going to have to do
bitcoin is a global phenomenon there's
150 plus million people around the world
that hold it it's a decentralized
digital payment system it is superior to
all other payment rails jenna yellen
realizes that she went she did her
homework she's now all in on the bitcoin
game and your favorite politician
appointed official or ceo they're gonna
be right behind her bitcoin's inevitable
and we're just starting to see the long
long line of people who are gonna have
to capitulate and join the bitcoin game
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time